in this movie black widow and dr. banner
have a closer relationship than they've
had in the previous ones can can you
describe that relationship from each of
their characters points of view um
these characters have a much like what I
would have met what I always thought was
a very unlikely love story that buds
between them actually kind of is there
much it's actually in truth rooted in a
very likely love story these characters
have a lot in common they are two people
that are really you know I think
idealizing this future that they have
that they could have with one another
and and which is you know which is
really a result of their past I think
the fact that they have this kind of
fantasy of you know a normal life you
know finding themselves and another
person and being able to live their life
together you know they they have this
this one side of them and that draws
them and then this other side that is
the kind of divine you know this kind of
fate that they that they are you know in
store for and it's just it's a very
complicated relationship that they have
a kind of impossible love it seems
unlikely but isn't how would Bruce
Banner define their relationship
impossible everything so hard at the
desirable I think he I think he wants
that more than anything and and it's a
completely undeveloped part of who he is
and and and so I think he's these two
people are the ultimate Outsiders inside
the Avengers and I feel like they they
innocently sort of fumble into these
feelings that I don't think I don't
expected to have but mark tell us a bit
about how the relationship between like
Bruce and Tony has evolved and changed
to where we
find it in Avengers age of Ultron well
they they really started working
together and in age of Ultron and you
know Tony's always pushing banner and
pushing you know he pushes everything
past the limits and banner doesn't
necessarily like that but also banners
you know a renegade enough that he
actually experimented on himself and so
I think they both head into this they
both developed this artificial
intelligence together that can spoil
early completely goes out of control I
think everyone knows by now Scarlet tell
us a little bit about how not only the
emotional relationship between you know
Natasha and Bruce but also she becomes
an important tool in helping to deal
with the Hulk so talk a little bit about
her role in helping The Avengers with
the Hulk in general how does Natasha
tame the beast it's a very good question
it's interesting that she does it with a
human touch I think because I imagine
that the last thing that anybody would
the your every instinct is telling you
like not to toughen the Hulk you know
and like he is also like putting that
out there he doesn't like want to turn
back he is like not the person that you
like grab and give a bear hug to and yet
like somehow it's almost in some ways
like he's like wait it's like a kind of
raging person that like needs a bear hug
in a sense or like a tender bear hug
like needs somebody to like kind of come
behind them and like remind them that
they're like grounded and there's
somebody with them and they're like
present and they'll come back to
yourself and it's kind of like if
they're sort of like a therapeutic thing
that she develops with Hulk and you know
I think that probably comes from her own
maybe maternal instinct that she has now
because of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
you guys are never too far separated
from each other like the whole cast I
know what was it like getting the whole
cast back together again
for this one it was fun I mean it's a
great it's such a great group of people
and and we've all sort of have grown
together and had families and and then
we don't see each other for a long time
and we come back together and it's sort
of like we're off again
and and it's playful everyone's super
fun and thoughtful and generous and has
great sense of humor very playful I just
feel bad for Jost who has to try to
wrangle this herd of cats and and get us
to do something simultaneously but um
yeah like see lines ya understand the
scenes about those kinds of little
things
you